kim kardashian wearing that dress this  is the dress that marilyn monroe wore to  sing happy birthday to president john f  kennedy 60 years ago this is the actual  dress take a look at the side by side  side by side that is the actual dress  according to kim look at that wow both  stunning  i'm a big what do you mean by actually  she they remade the dress no the actual  accessories according to kim that is the  dress that marilyn monroe wore 60 years  ago to serenade president anyway happy  birthday yeah yeah well actually i don't  know please continue  you're my best breathy marilyn monroe  you're teasing me yeah yes i have it i  am going to pop out of a cake  are you so you never know nicole you  never did  a real present